wow so welcome back
how did you like the conference so far
awesome
thank you very much but it's a pleasure
to hear that thank you you know all good
things have to come to an end
oh
so welcome to the closing session and we
want to highlight some things and with
some some material prepared for you of
course so I want to remind you the
conference is run by volunteer experts
and I would like to welcome everybody
from the organ team to the stage
please come
on
is anyone left
right
so thanks also all the volunteers who
joined us on stage already
okay yes I we did plan to do this from
reboot with two more volunteers come up
so give them the map as well
[Applause]
thanks to all the session chairs who
shared a session
please stand up
huh yeah yes yeah thank you thank you
thanks to all the speakers who gave a
talk or tutorial
please stand up
thanks to the sponsors
I think we can just
okay so we want to thank again our
Diamond sponsored the IL
um jetbrains
you want to take yeah eBay and mobile
day a snowflake
and all our Platinum sponsors and our
gold Spencer also a big round of
applause for everyone making this
financially possible
thanks to the BCC thanks to Pierre
Michelle who helped us like setting us
all up up front during calls maybe from
here they are there actually so thank
you very much
I thought
also thanks to the catering team how did
you like the food
and also thanks to the security team and
everybody else from the BCC team was
when Walter well as the technicians the
video Engineers from the BCC thank you
very much
okay
so here again here is a team that make
this event possible so and thanks
everyone to make it possible so that we
can organize such a great events and
just for the organizers if it's your
first time organizing such Heaven please
raise your hand
so
foreign
to be one of the first so yeah
so in during this three days we had uh
115 sessions and thank you to all the
speakers the facilitators and everyone
involved to make that happen
um
thank you very much
and yeah I just wanted also to share
some fun numbers like that's the number
of peers that we had by by day on the
conference and I think so we had our
call for proposal here we had this first
Peak then we had our continuous work and
just before the conference that's where
we start panicking
and also yeah probably most of you know
now how to use Discord in some way
another and yeah we also had our Discord
Registration Board that helped us access
to the different channels and just give
you a small idea of what happened with
our account and invalids over time and
you see we had a pretty short night uh
between the start and the end so yeah
it's pretty interesting to see and yeah
it's a very interesting uh thing that we
wanted to extract from what happened in
this conference
and you really use well this call it was
definitely a pretty nice surprise to see
how people shared some nice picture of
the pets So yeah thank you very much
it was pretty fun
[Applause]
okay
laughs
hi everybody in case you're wondering
who won the PlayStation
we will resolve this riddle now
um
just a reminder you have to look at your
ticket very top ignore your initials and
ignore the underscore and the minus
the winner is
five
m i S one
please contact us
no worry okay where is he again
once again once again
yeah come on
congratulations
[Applause]
thank you
I just want to say thanks to my friends
Natalie for for being there
so
we had 7 attendees
we know that already anyone can switch
from to remote which was really handy
also I watched some talks this morning
from the hotel some other things too we
have some actually where's the video
team to read all these stats
hey come on here
yes
so tell us a little bit more about video
production
everyone
um so yeah over the next over the last
three days
we had around 9 000 views you know in
our streams uh over 2000 to 290 days of
view time and over 1
100 unique viewers so pretty cool it's
nice to see
um yeah thanks everyone for tuning in
thank you
and also as far as I know no major
outages so everything went smooth
if you if you ever wondered how 700
attendees allowed is only a thousand
here in the room this is a picture taken
from the stage from the opening session
so this is actually how you look like
when you joined good morning I'm uh I'm
pretty sure you have the same energy of
the three days of conference even more
uh as like any opening session but we
just want to share with you from you as
with you as well
thanks to pie ladies for all their
outstanding contributions there was a
Pilates stand throughout the whole
conference there was always there
approachable coming Pilates lunch the
Pilates Workshop there's many Pilates
around here please every pie lady please
stand up or show a hand if you're on
stage because we have many on stage as
well
and now is the report of the code of
conduct team
I think this one here you go
um I am very happy to announce that we
have a total of zero incidents being
reported
and
this is by one side amazing we could see
and feel how this conference is um
wonderful but as uh Teresa just gave a
really good talk about it recommend you
to see it the code of conduct is being
rethinked because it's not because we
didn't have reports that someone didn't
feel annoyed so we are very we will be
very happy if you can write an email if
you feel that way that you didn't know
how to report so we can improve even
more next year thank you
thank you
and yeah some nice things so by data
Berlin this pycon Pi data Berlin is the
end but there are new new events coming
up so Pi data Amsterdam coming up in
September
we have also played it at London coming
up sooner in June and even sooner we
have jupitercon in Paris coming up
that's all around Jupiter it's really
amazing the conference used to be in the
States now it's in Paris which is really
great and if you're in Jupiter then
it's a place to eat in May
conference videos will be made available
to all attendees by the end of the week
watch your mailbox and we're going to
release them later on YouTube in a few
weeks later they're going to be
accessible to everyone in public but
we're going to share with the attendees
to cut video links up front so what's
your inbox
are you looking forward to the videos
and now the tradition Fun With Flags
who remember who could has anybody an
idea what Fun With Flags could be who
was around last year
okay
so okay fun with flex you know like we
run this conference we we try to run
this conference as sustainable as
possible so vegan vegetarian food we try
to avoid printing things and but some
things we still want to have because
they look nice like
Flex
so like his Flex this is like the flags
that we're outside in the building for
outside the building they're bigger than
I thought actually
so and now on the side yes yeah so
pretty cool so if you ever want to have
a blanket with pie data Berlin to sleep
in it
um we we did brainstorming it's also
very suitable you can have like a sun
sail
um there's multiple things or just like
hang a flag somewhere here and we
decided okay I think it's a it's a quite
unique memorabilia so we decided to give
them away to you on a first come first
serve basis so who wants to have this
Slack
and okay now everyone's coming oh
we have five Flags though decide now
here here you go oh yeah you're welcome
we have the pike on the E flag
yeah so
oh fun with flash
uh yeah you can also yeah of course here
you go
yeah we don't we don't open them it's
like just like we have another I think
Pike on the E flag right building
yes here
nice oh sorry but we have two more two
more Flags
[Applause]
laughs
oh okay here you go
this one
more I think that's the thought here we
go this we have the last one the last
one
here yes yes yes
so yeah sorry that's it see you next
year thank you very much